yeah I was going to say like for you
you're one I mean there's amazing uh
female Personalities in the Sports World
um you're one of the only women who has
kind of uh
a main role on a debate show at this
point where you're not just like kind of
move like you said moving the segment
you're you know you're you're there as
somebody who gives their opinion every
day for you has it been like
uh you know I do think sports fans for
the most part can be kind of
misogynistic in terms of like the sexism
and [__] like that but you've done a
really good job of like navigating what
I would say like for me when I was in
radio it's like you start off as an
intern then you maybe do weekends and
you've kind of built your way up to
having your own show now how hard is
that being a female and doing sports
like because you are I mean you could
correct me if I'm wrong but are you like
one of the only females who actually in
the opinion space there's very few of us
I don't want to misspeak but maybe one
or two that do uh daily like are on the
show every day as a opinion show that's
not directed towards a specific uh sport
right which you know I would love for
there to be more right
um it's never my goal to be the only one
um it's yeah I mean my career has always
been
um growing and adding to my resume and
the process so like I said I started as
a unpaid intern in Miami and then I was
like a full-time intern and then a
part-time producer and then a full-time
producer and then you're a freelancer on
the side while you're producing and you
know you kind of always have multiple
jobs in this business also right but
yeah I mean I I've I've earned my way up
and built my way up but also
I don't know I think
I think it's all in how you not all in
but partly for me it's been learning
from the people and the the
personalities that I worked with
skip is very different than Colin is
very different than Shannon is very
different than the manual is very
different than shady is different than
last like there's different than Zazzle
in Miami everyone has different things
they bring to the table but you're going
to get criticized no matter what you do
you're going to get criticized more if
you're a woman and you're gonna get
criticized more if you're a black woman
so
for me the misogyny and you know people
even I mean today you can go look on my
social media there's somebody's gonna
say I'm shouldn't be there because I'm a
girl okay whatever like yeah those
people don't sign checks so who gives a
[__] they just they don't those people
don't make decisions right they don't
move the needle because for the most
part people are watching and enjoying
good content entertaining content
educated opinionated
content that they resonate with I'm not
saying things that don't make sense
right if you disagree with me it's easy
to say you disagree with me because I'm
a girl but then you're gonna run into
somebody else that says that that's a
man and now what are you gonna do now
what are you gonna do so it doesn't
really I've also have a built up a very
thick skin for it I've seen you snap
back at trolls before yeah I say I'm in
retirement now uh mostly because Twitter
is just not as fun as it used to be
right like it just doesn't provide the
same uh same level of entertainment for
me anymore but yeah I mean I don't I'm
happy to you know embarrass somebody or
you know ruin someone's day for sure but
for me it's more about
it's more about letting people know this
isn't this isn't really actually
affecting me and it does certain people
how you approach social media for
everybody in the business is an
important conversation you have to have
with yourself right and to me I'm like
if you wouldn't come to my face and say
this to my face which we know you would
not do that of course you're not going
to do that for sure I can't take you
your criticism seriously in any capacity
if if you if I wouldn't ask for your
advice I don't care about your criticism
right that's some that's some real [__]
I think everybody should have that
that's I mean it's not easy to develop
that though I mean it's there's it's
easier to let you get to you too like
even if you don't think like consciously
it's happening subconsciously you think
about that stuff well the subconscious
part is the interesting part because I
think everybody has a different capacity
to deal with feedback the reality is we
know too much about each other we should
not know this much about each other in
society and we all get too much feedback
good and bad so 10 000 people can tell
me I'm right and 10 000 people can tell
me I'm wrong in one day neither one of
them are changing my spirit it's just
it's just not a good habit to have it's
kind of like being an athlete yeah like
you can't you can't get so down because
you lost a game that you can't focus on
the next game right or miss a shot or if
you throw an interception you gotta you
know you got to come back and be a
goldfish yeah so I I that's just how I
approach it but I feel like it's
important for everybody to find their
own way to deal with that kind of
feedback